foreign
[Music]
so this one is white to play and
obviously when I need to run the I need
to take a leak so you can start thinking
I'll be thinking in the bathroom
I need more time and you can see them in
your head so it sounds good with me all
right I'll I'll keep my uh yeah all
right good luck I'll be right back folks
um I I could explain where I am so far
I did I think I found in the bathroom
but you can also take more time rumbling
to myself
um no no it's fine
um okay I mean I was looking at Knight
F7
um this is the line that I was getting
the deepest in but I had not completely
figured it out yet
I think it's the only move
yeah
I was looking at at night F7 because you
don't you don't want to let the king
Take the pawn
um and then there's a lot of options
here thingy six King D5 King D4 but the
the big issue that I was trying to solve
is if I'm trying to push D7 there's this
check right and that seems problematic
um and I also didn't see any way to win
the night because of course if you win
the night you're also winning
um so like I was looking at King E6 and
was thinking okay if I make a move like
Bishop B3 this looks promising
um if the King goes to D7 you check and
yeah honestly this one had so many
variations that it was taking me more
time it does have a lot of variations to
be completely honest with you so King F6
loses on the spot right we can agree on
that because of D7 yep
um I think King D4 is what I sort of
started with
informally and again I think framing
the task is important because in in our
minds we could say oh the only way white
wins is if you go D7 and d right but
there's a second way to win which is
basically to pick up the Knight if you
win the night assuming you know how to
mate with Knight and Bishop it is
winning
so I think the move here is just
directly going after the night I think
it's it's straightforward
um I I thought about that too like
trying to take away the the knights
Escape squares but then I thought after
he takes then we have to figure out how
to get this one so that's why you play
King F5 but I think it's more because
King F5 maybe uh maybe that is winning
takes and King E6 yeah that also is
winning I think Bishop H7 too is is
winning
uh oh because if you checked King F5
yeah
okay I'll I'll put it on the board
um
check takes take and then there's no way
to catch it bingo
or your move I think F5 is very nice and
King E6 and Bishop H7
I wonder if there's any trick here for
black
is forced yeah
and then
E6 you can play here right and then you
have five we should bake seven
regardless but black could try to push
the king E3
and then he does start pushing
I think this might be a draw actually
we can check the engine in this position
okay let me know what it says it's
winning it's winning oh look at how it's
winning 95
D3 you go Bishop F7
D2 Bishop H5 now still not over because
black could try to make it to you one
but the moment he does
you have Knight D3 check pushing the
king away and then you go around and get
the pawn
it is a draw though
because in this position black draws
with King to C3
and apparently of course obviously I
mean just for the benefit of the chat of
course I saw this
because the point is if you do the same
exact thing if you go here and then you
go here remember that with a king on E2
White had Knight D3 check now the King
goes from the other side oh oh this is
insane Knight C4 black to move only move
to draw
well I I think I think I saw the
computer but it's D1 equals Knight it's
D1 Knight oh because it's the only one
that stops 93 yeah unbelievable D1
Knight is the only drawing move and
Bishop and Knight versus knight is a
dead draw
yeah so I think Bishop H7 is the only
winning move here
um for that reason and
I just confirmed that Bishop H7 yeah wow
okay
so but that means king E6 to be honest
is the only move I really devoted a lot
of time to
and here you correctly suggested Bishop
E3 check
I think
right King D7 yeah it did suggested but
I hadn't seen it all the way through yet
so here I think you should you should
think because Knight E5 check is a draw
right because of King tastes
yep can we generate other ideas
generating
um
and remember like don't get fixated on
just the prospect of winning the night
always keep it flexible like you have
two major goals to push the Deep on and
to win the Knight
your 95 tries to go for the first goal
it fails is there a move that goes for
the second goal
well I was also looking at King G5 and
if anything like that works but I don't
think it does right but you're still
going after the night can you try to
push the d-pawn
uh yeah I I was looking at that too I
was thinking Bishop A4
um but I think my issue with that was
key six and if I push the Knight comes
check stub yep stop burning us
yeah which I'm not gonna give up on
for sure uh
okay you'll see it if you stare and
stare long enough at that position
okay
I mean there must be some way to win the
night after all of this
I'm trying to find it no rush
uh because even variations with Knight
d8 after doesn't he play King B6 and
he's getting out of it but look yeah
winning the night is impossible but
there's something else you can do of
course there is
um
oh oh oh
uh is there a
oh okay okay okay so I think it's
Bishop A4 King E6
you push
five
ping F4
takes
night
checking takes
it's King D at that at that point King
D6
oh
there is a well what's the only other
way to win the game if you're not
winning the night
I mean to to promote somehow no you're
forgetting about to Checkmate right okay
yes okay um and I'm trying to find the
checkmates okay Bishop A4 King E6
um
I think D7 is taking a lot of that's
what I was trying to do with King F4 I
was trying to find if there's any way to
get the king in to take away the E5
Square which is why I played King of
four and then Knight takes
oh but the King has the black king has
F6 there yeah yeah okay so can we take
that square away can we take the F6
square away just play King G5 Knight
takes D7 and then it's Checkmate on B3
excellent damn I totally missed that
there should be three made in the final
position so we should make the moves on
the board yeah we should because it's a
beautiful mating construction
yeah sorry D7 Knight F6 you have to play
King g5s take away this Square takes
and this is mate
yep
damn
so
one recommendation I have I was forced
to do this when I was maybe two thousand
twenty one hundred
um I was I did this with my dad from a
real book but now there's anything yeah
I just heard four
um there's a there's a chessable
equivalent now which I I can recommend I
know
people are going to roll their eyes at
this but again I did this and uh it
really really helped me it's um
basically accelerating your pace of
detecting checkmates
um and yes I was forced to do made in
one puzzles by like the hundreds uh at
that level there is a chessable course
called I think mates in one two three
and four and there's like a thousand
exercises and I think if you do all of
them you will notice how how much better
you are at essentially detecting mating
mating Nets and mating patterns
and what's the name of this course I'll
give you the link to it I'm gonna go
full cam and I'll link you in Discord
thank you
maybe I'll do a stream stream doesn't
end until I've done a thousand it's
mastering mates too 111 two move three
move in four move checkmates how long do
you think it would take me to do that
um all 1 000 of them well depends on how
much you do per day
but it would be I think it would be
super fun thing to do on stream
oh yeah I mean I might do it
I might do it no I actually I think I
should think I actually think it would
be good how would you break it up if you
were me so I would focus more on the
three and four move checkmates and I
would try to do something like 20 or 30
per day
okay
um and the Maiden two puzzles I would
try to do they're 650 Maiden twos I
would try to do them in two days maybe
you can do like a marathon
I think the marathons would be fun
do you think I could do all the maiden
twos in one day I think you could that
would be incredible if you did all 650
of them
damn
at what point do you think I'd start
going crazy
like about 100 to 100 of them in into it
I really think um this is like to
Hammer's point of course this is this
will be easy but there's two types of
there's two types of tactical Vision the
first is like understanding concepts and
the second is detecting stuff that you
know exists but finding it faster like
you know a mate exists but actually
finding it uh requires just like rote
pattern recognition and wrote uh like
ability
that's why Hammer likes puzzle rush
because it just it sharpens your pattern
recognition and it feels like pattern
recognition is the subconscious part of
playing chess and it's always working so
you want to sharpen that even if you
don't know how strong it is exactly
exactly
um okay honestly that sounds like a fun
stream idea
I think people will really enjoy it I
mean I might do it with like maiden
threes made in force
or we should both do like the 650 in one
day you should race I mean you would you
would do them a lot faster I feel like
if I'm doing doing that you should have
to do like 3x the amount
yeah maybe a 24-hour stream where all I
do is make puzzles what if we had a race
you have to do thrifts and let's see who
gets there first that would be
interesting actually going insane not a
bad idea not a bad idea
yeah that that would be a lot that would
be a lot um but you know what I'm going
to be doing a lot of Chess preparing for
Iceland so
it could be one of the things you factor
into your rotation but yeah this
freaking puzzle is mind-blowing this is
a this mating pattern is crazy
yeah this is very beautiful I I I I I
struggled with this one more than the
others
um
I I
I don't know why I think it was because
there was so many King moves that I was
trying to calculate them all and then I
was I thought I found Knight F7 maybe
one minute so I basically had like one
minute to start looking at that it was
just not enough time for me that totally
makes sense and again you know like
normally in a classical game you'd have
more more time to think but one of the
key takeaways really is uh keeping the
goal flexible right but you get fixated
on on you have to do this one thing that
causes freeze and when you freeze it's
like you the wheels are spinning and
nothing's you know the car isn't driving
but constantly reassessing okay is this
the only way to win maybe there is a
mating pattern maybe I don't need to and
one of the ways that this uh relates to
real chess if you want I could show you
a quick example yeah please uh one of my
favorite uh Concepts and I've shown this
game on stream before several times so
some people will recognize it
uh there's a concept that when you're
attacking your opponent's king a lot of
people get into Checkmate mode where the
only thing they look for is ways to
deliver Checkmate whereas I see this in
puzzle Rush a lot too yeah whereas let's
say 50 of attacks The Logical conclusion
is actually not to Checkmate it's to win
material it's to use the weakness of
your opponent's king in order to in
order to somehow win material so here's
an example for one of my games
um maybe I've shown this I don't think
I've shown this to you
I haven't seen a position yet so no I
think I just pasted it okay cool no I
don't think I've seen this before
awesome I think you'll enjoy this one
so it's white to play I cut through some
of the BS earlier in the game we got
right to the critical position so white
to play and win
uh I won't give you any other
information I'll let you think about it
for a bit
okay
um I'll think about it and I'll let our
chat think about it too
awesome
too many pieces says rough crash
so remember the theme here which is that
I've muted myself in Discord
it's like you look at black skin and
you're like okay queen h8 queen H7 check
but the tactic has nothing to do with
delivery I mean endgame studies are hard
but they're nice because at least
there's not so many pieces they're clean
yeah they're cleaner
Queen h8 looks very juicy
it does what does it threaten
Rook H7 are you sure that's a threat
I was before you asked me that question
so Knight takes let's say I let you play
those moves Queen h8 Rook H7 you play
Knight takes H7 what a A6
oh uh okay
well this was what I was oh I saw I was
calculating this but that makes sense
because if you play here I could take it
the Knight
okay
so let's say I go King E8
um
oh you're right it's not and it's messy
and it's important when you're
calculating to label that so it's you
don't know what the evaluation is here
it could still be winning for white but
this is very undesirable because it's
messy and it's hard to evaluate and you
want to avoid positions that are hard to
evaluate
that's true so that's true some people
are suggesting E6 by the way after King
E8
but it's too freaking slow E6 King G8 I
run
yep I run
yep and this is Checkmate mode this is
sorry I need to help my task probably
with one more thing you might give me
another thing no rush at all
yeah so
basically this is Checkmate mode where
you're fixated on
trying to deliver the Checkmate but if
we go back to the initial position some
of you already got it the key is to
observe is to make an observation on the
queen side which seems to have nothing
to do with what's going on on the king
side this is impossible to solve unless
you make a crucial observation of one
sort
the question is what is this observation
and if you guys watch My Stream
regularly you know how obsessed I am
with undefended pieces and this example
is a good illustration why
Queen is undefended yeah the queen is
undefended also the Rook is undefended
but that's not important the only
important thing is that the queen is
undefended the moment I noticed that you
should be able to see the move like if
you look carefully at the king side and
what you have to offer
so
yeah I've shown this in speed runs I've
shown this position in a speedrunner
because I think it's it's such a clean
illustration of this concept so I
you know I don't like showing the same
thing over and over and over again but I
have other examples but this is like
very very
clear-cut you know
so we'll see if Alex can find
the key move
once we get to the right observation
so Queen H6 doesn't create any threats
Queen H6 doesn't create any threads
yeah uh at test you got it
the first move is okay I won't say what
it is because oh I am muted in Alex's
chat so okay I'll say what the first
move is which is Knight F4 takes G6
it's Knight takes G6 sacking the Knight
to two different pieces one of the
important things is to understand Knight
takes G6 Knight takes G6 what squares
are now accessible to your pieces which
is a good question to ask if you're
calculating a line that involves a
sacrifice or a capture you need to
reassess the situation like where can I
now go
well obviously Queen H7 check you pick
up the Knight and the attack is totally
decisive so Knight takes G6 King takes
G6 is the big question my opponent
played B3 which is the trickiest move
but Knight takes G6 King takes G6 again
if you look for checkmate you're not
gonna find it if you broaden your view
of the board you'll find the sequence
immediately
yes as you can see this is my game
I was playing white here this is uh Riga
2016.
yeah okay hopefully Alex
it's back soon and we'll tackle this one
no I I'm done now one of my friends was
supposed to come because they might want
to rent one of the rooms and live with
us and I totally missed all of their
messages so I don't know if they're
gonna come today anymore okay
uh it's okay
it's so fun you can take if you need to
like do your thing or go that's totally
fine no I I'm actually done because
Andrea's home so she's um and I I also I
texted my friends they know Andres home
so we're all good and I'm back to this
position okay so awesome now just to
make sure we're on the same page we kind
of rejected Queen h8
yep so Checkmate mode will not yield any
good moves you have to make a critical
observation on the other side of the
board there's something that you can
exploit on the queen side so even
without looking at any moves can you
maybe spot what that is and we talked
about this before the importance of
noticing these things and you know what
you had hinted that before the game so I
already figured it wasn't going to be
Checkmate but I had miscalculated the
queen h8 line and thought who's winning
material
um and also when you quickly glance at
the queen side it's not honestly obvious
that there's anything going on here
because it doesn't look like black has
any weaknesses there no not weaknesses
but undefended pieces are very
combinable with King weakness when the
king is weak it opens up the possibility
of a lot of discoveries and a lot of
forks so you should notice what the
undefended pieces are on the queen side
The Rook is undefended the pan on C4 the
pawns are not important
the queen I mean the Queen's also
undefended but I don't see how we're
going to attack it straight off the bat
okay but look more carefully as a hand
the queen is the piece that you're
actually trying to win here which is
ridiculous sounding
if that look it just looks so strange
that that could be a thing here
so look at the king side and see if you
can set up a some sort of device that
ultimately wins the queen on A5 okay so
ideas is like a queen on H5 and a check
um
okay so Knight takes G6 if King takes
you play
wait if King takes yeah anything but
yeah I guess Queen H5 King goes back
um and then the easy move the easy move
is on the hard work look at black screen
on A5
look at your queen but there's no checks
oh
yeah and again you've got fixated on E6
again yeah I want you to notice how two
things are making it hard the first is
you're like May the second is in your
mind I think you came up with the move
E6 but you got to keep it flexible the
goal is not to play E6 it's to win
Black's Queen
right right okay that's a good point
um so Knight G6 you can't take with the
King but he can take with the Knight
um then it's straightforward
I mean then Queen H7 looks very good and
you don't have to calculate any further
because then you're up a pawn and you're
made you're winning everything right
yeah
this is a very instructive position
actually yeah I think I think it is and
it has nothing to do with the fact that
I want you I don't care about that in
the game my opponent tried a desperation
move B3
a b c b and I'll make it a little bit
easier by saying that BC isn't a big
threat because the king can't really be
be checked so here I found the the key
follow-up move
same theme
wait
I mean you do have some checks after
this queen A4 B3
uh okay yeah that's fair so the only
other way the only dangerous check is
Bishop C8 to F5 so whatever you do you
also have to prevent that but there is a
move which does everything
I mean queen H5 looks juicy but not so
much because I guess you could just take
one
the night okay but don't forget the name
I mean you can't right away because it's
E6 yeah
um oh and then what else are you
threatening with Queen H5 I mean you're
threatening who's like Knight at four
yeah Knight F4 is just made it's made in
two you made in two yeah
um okay so Queen H4
B takes King takes
Queen A4 check B3 Queen goes back and
then you have Maiden two
bingo
bingo I I had a lot of assistance but I
did get
it I mean it's hard it took me this was
a classical game it took me like 15
minutes so obviously I'm not showing
this to really like to test you I think
you would totally find it with like
unlimited time in the game my opponent
actually missed E6 he took on G6 here
and after E6 he he was like he like
jumped back in his chair
did he really that's so funny he did he
did so one more thing which is hilarious
the queen was not undefended what's
crazy is that you have a way of actually
winning The Rook here as well after King
takes G6 this illustrates the power of
undefended pieces let's assume that the
queen was not on A5 but on A6 what would
you do in that case
Queen G3 gang F7
and then yeah and The Rook can also be
one yeah no that's very pretty a puzzle
within a puzzle yep exactly so just to
show this here here picks up the roof so
this isn't any of your chest books not
yet this is uh I'm keeping this for
saving this for a rainy day
that's a very very nice game
so that the conclusion is when you're
attacking try to be as broad as possible
in your goals like remember that you can
win material and it's just like when
you're setting yourself an objective
don't tie it to one particular move like
if you're thinking I have to win the
queen don't think okay I have to do it
by playing E6 because that sometimes
prevents you from finding other
executions of the same idea if that
makes sense yeah that makes sense
cool but then
so let's say you were playing you you
did play this this tournament I mean you
must have been scanning
um this position for a while before
finding Knight takes G6 right
yeah I mean I was thinking about Queen H
shade I was thinking about e takes F6
but Knight takes G6 is also a capture so
if you follow the rules you should this
should be on your radar even without
realizing what the idea of that move is
yeah so it's like one of those things
okay so then when you're attacking are
you
your general ideas
so you're looking at forcing moves and
captures and that is true I don't think
that's an overblown uh piece of advice
yeah you're looking for uh you know for
the checks captures and threats and the
standard stuff
I'm actually one second I'm seeing if I
can
there's an example that I kind of want
to show on that topic
uh which is like yeah you're looking at
captures and you're looking at checks
that advice though can fail
if you let your brain control the
process because what often happens right
is that there is a capture but you're
not really taking it seriously so one
lesson I learned is like take every
single move equally seriously and give
every one of these moves a chance that
is how you find like hidden ideas
and I have an example of what I mean by
that
um which I was just trying to find so
let's consider an example for everything
they're always good though let's
consider this position
so I'm playing white here this is a
classical game from Guitar donchenko's
now like 26.80
um of course everybody's past me
but in this position I'm playing white
it's white to play and win and I played
a very serious mistake that could have
cost me winning missing an immediate win
and try to apply the you know the
process look at every move and take them
all seriously
that's what we're applying here right
and be stubborn like you might reach a
point you're like oh this is just
Perpetual or this doesn't really do
anything but try to look a little bit
deeper and remember that quiet moves can
come at the most unexpected of times
okay
um
all right so
first looking at the forcing moves Queen
F4 Knight G4 Knight takes F5 just kind
of thinking about all of them
um so let's see if we play
Queen F4 since that's the easiest one to
calculate let's say King G7
um and you are down material here so it
feels like a draw would be a good thing
but no because I I know that you could
do better than that also Black's King is
in such uh such a bad spot you would
wanna
yeah that's true
um okay so me being stubborn here I
would think more than just this check
but I don't
think this is the line I mean you could
also take on F5 but that's not good and
your king is kind of escaping so I I
don't think queen of f4 is a good move
nope um okay cool uh
the other thing is I wish if our King
had an escape score I wouldn't be
worried about these background checks
because that would force me to bring
back one of my attacking pieces because
then there would be ideas like Knight F6
maybe could be interesting
um okay let's see so other ideas
um so you've already named them Queen F4
is ruled out what were your other
candidobes
so Knight G4 Knight G4 you have to take
with the F Pawn
um and does that do anything like is
there a way maybe to win a rook by doing
that not that I see
um because you still get this check
and your back rank is a week so even if
you were to win The Rook you would have
made it yeah exactly so I don't see
anything with that okay third candidate
move okay so Knight takes step five okay
it feels like he should take and then we
play Queen F6 check yeah okay uh King H5
uh you take oh we actually you don't you
could also play G4 but but you don't
need to do anything because you know for
a fact in that position you could take
the pawn and come back to F6 and you get
the same position without the F Pawn
does that make sense wait sorry say that
again so we can make the moves on the
board I mean this isn't really about
visualizing so it's
if you look at this position you don't
need to think about anything other than
Queen takes F5 check because you can get
this exact position with the pawn absent
from F5 yeah yeah you're right how could
you do that thinking about
um
I mean you could just repeat the
position yeah and now with the pawn gone
you get a whole host of other critical
ideas and in this position this is maybe
the hardest move to actually understand
okay well each three looks like a nice
move to consider here because you're
making space on the back and you're also
threatening checkmate
um what is the issue with H3
let's say queen D1 check
King H2
um
and then maybe like
broke G8 to stop it
but
I don't think it's Queen F7 because he
blocks you can also just push G4 and
make him sack everything Bingo and this
is where the second piece of advice
comes in because in that position you
you could spin your wheels and not find
Checkmate but the queen end game is
actually not even close it's so easily
winning so if we make the moves on the
board like H3 you can go ahead Queen D1
check
um
King H2 Rook G8 this is what I actually
missed I calculated up until this point
and I thought oh man I have to go into a
queen end game and it's not going to be
easy I I didn't take it seriously
so Queen takes G4 are there any checks
at all even hypothetically for black the
answer is no so what is the simplest
thing you can do
try to win a pawn not even necessary you
have what you need not even your pawns
push your pawns on close your eyes and
C5 that's it C5 the game is over
game is over for example there's
literally no checks there's nothing even
if King takes you for same thing nope no
even hypothetical checks now black and
try A5 and you do need a little bit of
calculation but once you reach this
point it's easy
wow how would you win here
um
to avoid checks okay so we need to help
support our Pawn
um
try doing it with checks
yeah yeah doing it with chess is always
nice
follow your guy I think you see the move
I would either go here I mean queen
queen E5 looks good
uh he's not gonna play here because then
we trade off and we win it's too easy so
he would probably go King H6 and then
you give him
uh another
you could do that there's a bunch of
different wins here
you could check here nice well I think
Queen F7 is even easier in this position
I think Queen F7 ends the game
immediately
oh okay I I guess Queen episode I was
like oh I still need to think about
these checks
right but now we have Queen f8
NCAA Queen and then yeah okay the new
block with the queen oh yeah that makes
sense that's even easier but even if you
don't block the queen one small piece of
advice sorry to I feel like I'm talking
up a storm here no you're educating
you're doing great so one thing I've
learned from experience is that you
should not be afraid of what I would
call checks in an open board it's
incredibly rare that a Perpetual happens
when your king is able to run into the
center and there are other pieces around
like obviously if white didn't have any
pieces then black would be able to check
forever if you have even a single queen
chances are you can escape a barrage of
checks and I think people really get
scared when they see a series of checks
um they don't realize often that when
the king runs into the center you will
find some way to block a check with the
queen you will find some Escape Route so
intuitively even if there's no Queen H3
You can conclude that this is like
completely winning
okay
I have an example of that too but we
don't have to delve into it
do you just have examples of everything
it's more that I think of so a lot of
the times I think of a game that I
played that encapsulates the theme
um and you know I quickly find it in
megabase so it's not like actually magic
you know
um no but but it does feel like magic
which is awesome this game also features
a really nice tactical exercise only if
you want let's do it nice okay um and
you could totally say no like I'm not
pushing you to to do these these
exercises yeah you're giving me free
lessons I am nothing but grateful I
appreciate it this is really fun so this
is another one my games
um and uh
there's a really nice tactic that it
starts with so this position was reached
um I was worse all game I made a
horrible mistake in the opening it was
worse all game my opponent's last move
was Queen you won the other game though
I I did but I made a huge mistake where
he could have almost equalized and then
he blundered a mate so that yeah I
played G4 there but it wasn't that
interesting
okay
um in this position my opponent has just
declined to draw two moves ago
and he played Queen C4 to E4
so white has a hidden
little magic in this position
okay so I'm just gonna think out loud
here if the Rook wasn't on A1 we would
be getting checkmated in in three moves
so we have to be careful
um
what else if you're at the the position
is equal material
um if we didn't have checks then Rook A8
would be super powerful is there any way
to get out of those checks like let's
say we played King H2
um with the idea of playing The Rook 2
A8
um
this Rook needs to stay there because it
has to defend to F6 uh so just to see if
it's a real threat let's say King H2
Queen takes E5 and then Rook A8 what are
we threatening we're threatening check
made in one which looks pretty serious
um and at that point you'd also be
threatening to take the queen so I think
Rook A8 is a serious looking threat that
being said I guess if you play King H2
you also have queen of things exactly
the F2 Pawn is undefended so black will
start harassing that pawn and you're not
gonna have the time to play Rook A8
well that is annoying isn't it um okay
so that doesn't work
what other kinds of moves would I
consider here to Interruption really
quickly
this is where it's important to extract
the positive from the line you just
calculated which is that you now know
what your objective is you need to go
over K8 and somehow you need to
tactically prevent The Rook C1 mechanism
rights
um that's that's a good way to put it
yeah The Rook C1 mechanism or the week
F2 Pawn but yep I guess that is I I
guess that is a hint
um
Queen G5 is an interesting option
um because it's keeping the pressure on
F6 while also defending C1 but it
removes the mechanism what's your threat
after Queen G5
it does remove the mechanism which is
why it was just a suggestion I'm sorry I
was I was not trying to like cut you off
you're not you're not you're not I like
it it's fixing my thing it's fixing my
thinking
um okay
gotta think outside the box here you
have a way to do what you want to do
it's just you probably see this move but
you might not be realized like how does
it actually help force yourself to look
at it
six doesn't do anything
so I don't see it being that sure wait
not to calculate it
I did not calculate it because it's a
crazy move Donya it is a crazy move but
again force yourself to look at those
moves and you will find that
like that part of your brain which is
dismissive and like ah this doesn't work
that doesn't work you don't want to let
it run the show
oh okay so E6 is already a little bit
interesting because F takes E6 doesn't
work because Queen E7 and then you're
opening the file for your Rook if the
king runs away you have Queen G5 so that
means that if you play E6
um black either has to take with the
queen or The Rook okay uh let's say he
takes to the queen that just feels a
little bit more defensive
um
if
oh what it's doing is it's getting this
yeah on H1 oh wait
that is
okay so E6 if Queen takes then you play
a rook A8
um Rook check no longer works because
there's no follow-up yep
um and then there's no way for the king
to get out so he'd have to make a move
like F5 that's clearly made
because of
Queen h8 yeah yeah yep
um
what about E6 E6 Rook takes C6 right
well that's kind of the same thing where
you get oh no it's not the same thing
because the queen is going to take on F2
so actually Rook takes is the trickiest
of them all
keep calculating though Rook A8 Queen E1
check again it's the same thing G2 24
check
and then you run away to H2
and that's the winning move
damn it's E6
um so just to show this on the board
you're right I I I I I totally
discounted this move
and I've noticed this in your thinking
which is very you normally see the move
like within a couple of moments it's so
important not to dismiss really anything
in chess because that's how you that's
creativity and why some players are more
creative I don't think it always is like
pure talent I think it also is
open-mindedness and the ability to give
certain ideas a chance when you're
tempted to just discount them
did you but you've had to kind of
understand all of these ideas to even
consider e-cigs so the creativity isn't
coming out of a void it's coming out of
a larger plan true right you've got to
spot the we should show to the viewers
like Rook A8 first of all some people
were proposing this
which is not the best move in the world
is The Rook defense but not in a good
exactly so rookie
everybody should see my viewers
no I had some people suggested not
trying to laugh at anybody so this gets
checkmated right Rook H1
yeah so the goal is to somehow Force
this mechanism to fail that's where E6
comes in either The Rook has to move
away from C1 or the queen has to move
away from H1 and either way Rook A8
works but that's not all
I played this move I was super excited
my opponent's next move sent me into a
bit of a cold sweat
so okay so it took like 30 minutes he
plays this move and my gut reaction is
oh my gosh how is was my move not
actually winning what is Black's idea
and this is how it relates to the actual
thing we were discussing earlier
what is Black's idea
um
well it's still holding on to C1 so you
can't move the Rook right away is it
threatening anything
uh
is this a threat not right away don't
discount it
damn it
Rook G3 FG black and try what
uh
uh Perpetual how or well is there really
a Perpetual well what what is Black's
attempt like you before even trying to
calculate it what is the actual idea
after Rook G3 FG
uh Queen E3 check and if you try to run
to H2 what happens
and if you try to run to H2 uh then
you actually do get Perpetual how
because you get Queen F2
um
wait
no I'm gonna have to queen queen G4
yeah are you sure you can't run away
with King Juan well that's exactly the
point right so I played he takes F7
okay and how does the line go you can
make the moves on the board and you know
you did tell us when it's an open
position you are going to be able to
survive it and there's one reason you
survive It Go On
um because the king runs towards the
center yep run right toward the center
Queen F3
so when you try to take I I guess this
doesn't even work but notice that Queen
is guarding the D3 score this is why I
said
when there's a queen on the board
normally that Queen is going to guard a
crucial square and disrupt the Perpetual
mechanism when she won chicken at this
point it's very easy how would you
propose to run away
uh I mean
just play King C2 because then
but what if I try to check on C5 I'll
try to defend stubbornly let's see how
quickly you can run away from the checks
uh uh okay still some finesse required
all right
uh
uh can't I just keep running upwards
okay
check
yeah that's the principle you keep
running toward the center and eventually
you just that's it Queen C sex check
and at this point
and the rest is easy I mean out of Queen
C2 whatever Queen D3 it's it's easy
uh is it well well actually you have to
be careful yeah okay King E5 that's it
five queen queen B2 Queen B2 Queen D4
and you move the king away with a check
of your own
nice yeah welcome off but it is
intimidating how far into this did you
calculate when you you took on F7
um I calculated up until once I saw that
Queen D3 was not possible that's I
stopped my calculation because I also
understood that The Rook is Untouchable
if black doesn't cap if black captures
the rook and it's not a check I will
always be able to promote so I did not
calculate past this move I knew that I
would be able to block with my queen and
it would be easy
okay
um wow
and there's a lot of cool examples of
this where you
you just have to realize intuitively
that anytime the king gets into quote
unquote and open board
um you now there's a secondary principle
here which is that sometimes especially
in Queen end games it's not enough to
just say oh my king is going to get out
of the checks what you need to do is
like chart a course and Charter course
to the right square and once that
happens it makes it oftentimes a lot
easier to figure out that there are no
uh that there's no Perpetual mechanism
just
it's comforting to know that you're
generally going to be okay in a type of
position
and once you know the principle that the
point of all of this is just to lessen
the amount of calculation that you have
to do so really really quickly if you
consider this position
this is a great example of something
where I think a lot of players would be
really afraid of getting Perpetual but
if you can chart the course and you know
where you're going you almost
immediately understand that there's no
Perpetual to speak of and you can just
continue doing your thing so I want you
to answer this in 30 seconds or under
white to play G7 because you can get the
king to H7
that's solved that's it G7 check
continue
um here Zed
and zag
I'd even give you the fun here
absolutely you don't give a damn about
these fonts yeah exactly yeah F7 or H or
the most classic line is check
H7
yeah H7 fans the final move and this is
the pretty part yeah that is the
destination Square
oh yeah true I should have said h8 I
just figured yeah I mean you were right
you got the vicinity
so that definitely helps that's a bit of
a detour but hopefully that gives you a
little bit of something to chew on
no this was a this was a great lesson I
like the examples it really helps cement
it in more and I I know that some of
these lessons I did know like the
solution because these were my games but
you know I I still think this was very
educational you know we did some where
we were both solving it and then maybe
somewhere you're you're explaining
things that I think are very important
and made it very clear
I'm really glad to hear that this is I'm
having an absolute blast so this was
incredibly fun I think we could build up
some momentum I love this I'm I'm really
down to do these like weekly or whenever
you have time I'm 100 down yeah like I'm
uh I'm actually flying to Utah uh
tonight in five hours so there's a Utah
chess Association is doing an event like
four streamers I um Rosen Gary me Nemo
uh and a couple others are are playing
and it's it's held in this Log Cabin an
hour from Salt Lake City
wait that sounds so cool it's incredibly
cool I mean I hope we don't all get like
kidnapped in that log cabin but oh God
yeah um it's it's gonna be super fun and
I'm using it as a bit of a vacation and
excuse like not to answer emails for a
couple days you know no that that makes
sense good luck that sounds awesome yeah
so I'm I'm my flight's at 7 30. which is
by the way the best thing ever
well thank you 7 30 p.m yeah like
evening flights are the best because you
can actually like not you know you can
wake up late and you don't I haven't
even packed yet
you know I know I I'm not a morning
person either I've been I've been waking
up this weekend and it has been rough
but it also is it's been nice being
forced to wake up early true
true but really Alex this is uh I'm a
late Riser yeah no I I woke up like 30
minutes before a lot before our session
so well I love that I was like oh it's 1
pm your time fine and you're like yeah I
could and you still look up
both of Sunday so I give my usually I'm
usually up around 11 like around between
10 and 11.
unless there's commentary and then I'll
wake up at six damn okay yeah you wake
up when it matters but I also just I
work late so I feel like sometimes
people who do look down on it they just
don't realize that I I work more hours
it's just I work much later so my hours
are shifted no I get it because
sometimes is easier to be more
productive at night yeah I definitely am
okay well Dania this was amazing thank
you so much I'm down to do it anytime
and good luck in the last cabin when is
the uh Iceland tournament just so I can
sort of it's on the 28th of April or
March uh no March in like 10 in 10 days
awesome so maybe 29th but I'm flying on
the 28th we can probably fit in another
session after I'm back from Utah and
this is a great pleasure Alexander
you're super fun to work with your
community is awesome so I'm always down
to do this
likewise thank you so much for for
taking the time I really appreciate it
thanks Alex we'll we'll be in touch uh
and I'll uh write you to set up the next
session
okay sounds good take care thanks
Allison are you too bye
foreign
[Music]